نحييكم من جديد لاكثر من اربعه عقود تعيش
ايران في دوامه من القمع والفوضى
والاضطرابات الداخليه عدا عن سلسله طويله
من العقوبات الدوليه التي وضعتها في عزله
ابرز تلك المحطات كانت في ابريل من سنه
1980 حينما اصدرت واشنطن قرارا بحظر توريد
السلع الاستهلاكيه وجمدت 12 مليار دولار
من الوصول الايرانيه بعد عمليه احتجاز
الرهائن في السفاره الامريكيه في يونيو من
عام 1995 اصدر رئيس الامريكي والسابق
بالكلينتون مرسوما بفرض حظر شامل على
ايران بتهمه دعم الارهاب الدولي في عام
2005 اعاد الرئيس الايراني محمود احمد
نجاد اطلاق البرنامج النووي وعلى خلفيه
الاشتباه في رغبه طهران في امتلاك اسلحه
نوويه اعلنت الامم المتحده سلسله من
العقوبات من جانبها حضرت الولايات المتحده
عام 2008 على البنوك الامريكيه العمل كو
في نقل الاموال مع ايران في عام 2018 سحب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
الولايات المتحده من الاتفاق واعاد فرض
عقوبات اقتصاديه شديده على ايران التي ردت
بالانسحاب التدريجي من الاتفاق منذ وصول
جو بايدن الى البيت الابيض في اوائل عام
2021 تفاوضت واشنطن بشكل غير مباشر مع
ايران للعوده الى الاتفاق النووي ولكن
الرئيس الامريكي واصل سياسه العقوبات ردا
على انتهاكات حقوق الانسان او تسليم اسلحه
ايرانيه الى روسيا او هجمات الكترونيه
عاود من جديد الى ضيوفي لمناقشه هذا الجزء
او هذا الشق من النقاش من بيروت مصطفى فحص
الكاتبه صحفي من دبي مسعود الفك الباحث في
شان الايراني وسابدا مع ضيفي من الشرقيه
الاستاذ كامل الخطيه الباحث والكاتب
السعودي اوسيف كامل كنا نتحدث منذ قليل
على ضغوط كنا نتحدث على مخاوف على معضله
قد يشهدها داخل الايراني لاستكمال او
لتنفيذ بنود هذه الاتفاقيه ولكن في
المقابل نحن عرضنا العقوبات التي تشهدها
ايران او شهدتها او سلطت عليها في فتره من
الفترات ولا زالت الى حد اليوم وهذه
العقوبات تعلم حضرتك بانها اضعفت النظام
كما يقول مراقبون وخرجت احتجاجات ونعلم
بقيه التفاصيل هل تعتقد بانه العمل
الاقتصادي قادر ان يوحد
قيادات ايران بشكل يمكنهم من الدفع لتنفيذ
هذه الاتفاقيه لانجاح خدمه للازدهار
لنبدا هكذا ضمن مستوى الصحف وتيره الصحف
الشعبي على النظام في ايران تصاعد هذا
اصبح امر امر لا يمكن اخفائه كذلك عامل لا
يمكن اغماله واهمال تاثيره في
السير ايران نحو تهدئه الاوضاع في الاقليم
دون المملكه العربيه السعوديه امر غير
مطروح طبعا لان الدوله الاهم في الاقليم
الدوله التي يمتلك القدره على
التوجيه اللي يعني على قياده الاقليم نحو
المستقبل افضل
لابد لابد ان نضحي العمر في الاعتبار ولا
ولا اعتقد انه في متابعين
يختلفون على اهم انه
النظام في ايران يسعى الى الخروج من
اختناقاتنا عم يسعائر الخروج واختناقات
على شك من خلال هذا الاتفاق بالتاكيد والا
نرجع مره ثانيه مره اخرى الى
اضرار
الكوميوني الى وقت الحرب وكان والتصريح
المشهور للقرار الحرب وكانوا يتجرا السم
هم في حد ذاتهم الرجال هذول القائمين على
هذا النظام هذا النظام العجيب الغريب
تنظم الاتفاقات وكاننا في نظرهم وكانهم
يتفقون مع الشيطان
النوع من النوع من التهدئه كانهم يعني
يخونون مبادئهم لكن هم مضطرين لانه في
واقع في الداخل
اذا استمرت تصاعد منسوب السقط الشادي
عليهم قد يؤدي الى انهيار نظام تماما احنا
شخصيا في الاقليم
يعني لا نوعد ان نرى الدم ونار في العراق
بالتاكيد لنقعد ان نرى ذلك ليس حفاظا على
النظام ولكن خوفا على تدحرج هذه الكرات
النار على الاقليم ايضا احنا معنيين
بيعملوا الاقليم الجغرافيا لا يمكن
تغييرها واحنا في
يعني متشاطئين من مصلحه من مصلحه المنطقه
ومن مصلحه الجيران كذلك ان تكون هناك حاله
من السلم ومن الامن ولكنك طرحت نقطه
اصطرار ايران الى اساعي لانجاح هذه
الاتفاقيه خدمه لمصالح الاقتصاديه استاذ
مسعود حول هذه النقد النقطه هل تضطر ايران
لذلك حتى وان كان على حساب موروث هاء
الديني موروثها الثورووي على حساب المبادئ
التي نشا عليها نظامها
ربما اقول هنا مقوله باللغه الفارسيه ولكن
مفهومه بالعربي بسبب كثره العربيه فيها
تقول حجز نظام او جبل واجباتاس اي الرب
وفهم في المفهوم
واجباته لكن بيناتهم
المؤسس للنظام حفظ النظام من اوجب
الواجبات في هذه الحاله يمكن للنظام حتى
يعطل مبدا شرعي لو تطلب الامر هذا التعطيل
هذا المبدا الشرعي يحافظ على النظام لذا
علينا ان ننظر الى الامور من هذه الزاويه
هذه هي عقيده النظام الايراني منذ عقود
على هذا الاساس تتجه لذا مواقفها ستكون
معقده ضمن هذه ضمن هذه المقوله الا ان
الاختبار هو سيد الموقف ايران بالنهايه
مهما كانت الاسباب انا اعيد واقول عليها
ان تلتزم بما توقع عليه كما ان الذين
وقعوا على هذا الاتفاق من الجانب الايراني
وهو علي شمخاني من هو علي شمخاني علي
شمخاني هو من مؤسسي الحرس الثوري الايراني
علي شمخاني كان قائد الحرس الثوري في
الاهواج ثم عندما كانت الحرس الثوري كانت
وزاره وكان وزير الحرس الدوري كان من
قيادات العليا للحرس الثوري ودوره في هذا
المجال لدى الان هناك يقف معه جيل من
الحرس الثوري اصبحوا رجال اثرياء اسمعوا
رجال اعمال في داخل
هو من هؤلاء الناس لذا هناك في الحرس
الثوري جيل صاعد هذا الجيل في واقع الامر
ينظر للامور
بمنظار الربح والخساره بمفهوم الاقتصاد
هؤلاء يريد الربح والخساره ولكن الى اين
استاذ مصطفى هنا سؤال حضرتك منطق الربح
والخساره على حساب المبادئ مبدئيا هل
تتوافق مع ذلك ام لديك شقوق اخرى في ما
يخص امكانيه ان
تحترم ايران هذه الاتفاقيات لمده تمكنها
من تحقيق اكبر بنود هذا الاتفاق مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
نعم اعتقد ان النظام الايراني كما قال
السيد مسعود
يتاجر بكل بكل المبادئه وعقائده ومعتقداته
من اجل حفظ هذا النظام والذي يدخل فيه
دائره المصلحه الشخصيه لاقطاب النظام
وساعطي رقم ومسؤول عن كلامي ان ايران تبيع
بالتهريب ما بين اثنين فاصله خمسه الى
ثلاثه مليون برميل في اليوم يدخل نصفهم
فقط الى الخزينه والنصف الاخر يظهر فليذهب
فسادا للاقطاب ومؤسسات داخل النظام والى
شخصيات اغنياء كنا نسميهم باغنياء الحرب
هم الان اغنياء العقوبات لدرجه ان هؤلاء
غير مستعد غير مهتمين بفك جزء من العقوبات
على على ايران
وكما ان الاستفاده ستاتي من هذا الاتفاق
لهذه القوى هذه القوه ستحافظ على على على
الاتفاق ولكن هل الاتفاق سيستمر هناك مثل
ايراني تمام جدا
باختصار يقول يقول ان ان الغربان مهما
غسلت من الغربانه لا يبيض لونها مهما غسلت
نفسها طيب نفهمه ونحاول مناقشته ولكن في
حلقه قادمه شكرا جزيلا لكم السلام عليكم